until las vegas has its own nba team the
next big thing for las vegas is the nba
summer league
sports director chris matthews live in
studio joining us with more on this big
event chris
yeah think about this brian when you
think about how big this event is really
it's nearly an entire season of games
played over a 10 day period it starts
out with 75 games
so it's nearly an entire season with
every nba franchise part of the thing
that wasn't always the case though it
started out small about 18 years ago
just a handful of teams in fact in its
early years some teams didn't want to
attend this
now nba owners demand that their teams
play in the nba summer league
the slogan here see tomorrow stars today
and it's true
every nba all-star today was a rookie or
a second year player who played in this
and remember last year because of the
pandemic the nba summer league was
cancelled but it's back
and fans can't be more excited
definitely i'm thrilled i mean it's
young
up and coming talent and even that seems
a lot of the nba players walking around
and we're all being cautious but it's a
thrill it really is that's a good
feeling uh
i love all the you know the safety
precautions with demands and everything
so it's almost back to normal uh it's
good seeing all the nba fans
nice crowd out here i'm quite i'm here
from atlanta oh wow
yeah so i came out to support dogs team
saw them play yesterday
big tray fan uh i'm excited i'm glad
it's back i'm looking forward to the
to the new season and check out some
more summer brian lopez wants the fans
to cheer every single second of these
games
but as you can tell they are not hey
each team will play five games and then
they'll see the teams once again
and work toward a champion memphis was
the defending champion we'll see what
happens this year